welcome to spoiler corner this ending
makes no goddamn son no no what not at
all I was really shocked that not as
much the movie because the movie has to
follow the book that the book tries to
have kind of this art house ending where
it's like what a shock they don't get
together that or at least they split up
at the end or she leaves him I guess
that's the empowering women part even
though she constantly goes back and
forth like I said that we said over and
over but according to my wife and this
is what she said and she she prefaced
this with like you know there's a totem
pole of insanity here but she said I'm
the totem pole of insanity the books
version made a little more sense really
yes she said that now she said it still
didn't make any sense but that the book
handled it in a way where it it made
slightly more sense than the film
version did like and I this is just what
was being paraphrased to me that was her
opinion but I mean I'm like but it still
made no sense right she's like oh not at
all but she's like it's still on that
totem pole of insanity it made a little
more sense of what the movie was doing
so so so pretty much this uh she's
trying to get more out of him and even
though he's bought her cars taking her
on airplanes and done all and revealed
stuff about his past he's like it's not
about love I'm not that kind of guy in
the bullsh t fucking horrible waiting
for character oh wait this is the
fantasy element of it yes like everyone
getting in you know you're getting him
to turn on you but he's still a road I
can I can change him yeah it always but
but can you change him enough and then
you had to know when to leave or
whatever so at the very so she wants to
get even more out of him even though to
be fair I think he said a fair amount
alike he said that you know he was a sub
with you was fifteen by one of his
mother's friends and then like what his
mother was like his real mother was like
addicted to cocaine or something I mean
or died while he was born I think a
crack baby or something yeah I mean it
did all this stuff so doctor yeah so
that alone would you like answer a
million questions about this guy that's
playing the movie why only one with any
actual character and it's not a lot it's
just more than what she has she but at
least
she literally in the movie is a piece of
meat yeah thank you she could have been
played by an inflatable doll because
there's just nothing an inflatable doll
that acts decent enough you know so so
we get to you know she says you must
tell me more must have no I can't it's
just it's too painful even though he's
all about pain but whatever uh so she
says okay well then show me it's the
only way clearly it's not he can tell
you because he's done so twice with two
big atom bombs but she says show me I am
giving you full permission to show me
all right and you think it's gonna be
like written over baby it ya know you
think it's gonna be like really fucking
into okay now he's gonna get like the
pêche of a Christ whip down or something
like that like do something really
fucked up
he just banks her a lot harder and says
count with me and he just he just gives
her a good lashing on here you know and
it's like which it looks like before
when he was in you know spanking her
before like it was already kind of hard
he's feeling a little bit of a hand
pronounced it's like already like a
chrono sight preview video number five
y-yeah thirty seconds of it like it's
and I'm like bet that's it
like III thought really we were gonna
see some like you know they're playing
like musicians and it's just what you
saw before except harder you know that's
their hardcore cuz he does it harder I
Danny Elfman's turning it up to Sleepy
Hollow language it's getting all creepy
and I'm like this is it so and when
they're done she says you know no you
are never to do me did do that to me
there that would be again either and you
are never to do me again that's actually
later
oh my god you're you're never to do that
to me again even though she gave total
permission to and honestly compared to I
think a lot of the audience's
imagination knows pretty tame so you
look at that whole dungeon like your
imagination runs wild like oh my god
what I'm doing and that's it yeah just
sort of hit a little bit with a crop and
a paddle that's really about it that
tiger up event I was like the other
thing and so she goes into her her room
because she has a separate room cuz he
doesn't do the love thing and he comes
in she says you know get your monster
you never do
ever get she's crying and Stephanie
Chesser sits there being you know
bewildered I'm tortured uh and she goes
I love you it's like where the fuck did
that come from
so and of course he says I don't do love
you know he's the same stick it's just
like that I'm leaving you so she walks
down to the elevator and then in a at
least in my opinion in one of the
strange twists of this entire movie the
best piece of acting out of both of them
happens in that last bit there because
he like runs to stop her like and you
can't tell if this is like a I'm
dominant running I'm going to stop you I
need you I nicking I agree and when she
says stop and he freezes and he gets
this panicked look in his eyes as is who
like and she says no or something like
I'm like that one moment I'm like holy
shit this is the only legitimately
interesting fucking scene and I do
remember that and again it was one word
it was all visual it was just their
performances and that I agree that was
actually really into absolutely in 30
seconds in this way you actually when
he's going towards her you have no idea
is he going to is he just going to go
after her or is he like going after her
like you can't tell there was a big
question and it was the only time in the
movie the lack of a narration actually
worked I mean the rest of it I think
we're all begging for Nia monologuing to
be back but she's a real movie for a
minute yeah it was a real movie for a
minute and then when does he say like
Anastasia Steele or something and she's
like Christian Grey and the door closes
what hey Anna you know Christian oh and
it was close is like VNL
yeah that's the ending is that it ends
with them you know with her leaving it'd
be like Oh which he kind of does
throughout the whole movie anyway it's
pretty like this whole idea of like you
know the dominant man is that mostly
it's inches we could be maybe maybe is
it like that's it ends on this light
Saturday morning cereal kind of
cliffhanger like and shit the Folgers
coffee and I love you long ago what will
happen see the next Folgers coffee
commercial go to this website to see
what will happen know it it's like The
Legend of Korra can we open the next up
sup
last time on Fifty Shades of Grey
we're like an episode of the old Batman
show oh no she's in quite a bind oh my
god but yeah so that that's the same
thing and clearly the way the movie is
set at the story I should say is set up
maybe if it was written well to it this
could work but it's clearly not diving
it was clearly a woman today and it's
not going into detail and it's not
making sense
there's clearly a role reversal and
she's clearly asserting herself in the
last 10 seconds of the movie but he
comes out of nowhere I'm like okay so
here's my issue with this you know
anybody that interesting things so my
wife was telling me about this book and
then she was reading me sections and we
were like literally laughing out loud
and that's I ended up talking to you
about it and Xing out the conventions
we're all reading it in silly ways yeah
you know so when this book came out I'm
like I'm really curious cuz when
Twilight came out I would keep reading
these reviews about how awful was so I
typed in Fifty Shades of Grey to look up
reviews of it because I'm like I have to
know what people are saying about this
because this just looks so silly a good
chunk of the reviews that came up were
from actual people into BDSM like
they're into the lifestyle the club
scene the you know everything those were
man first people that would go get it
the more I think about because they're
like oh but this is gonna tell my story
so it's like oh so I'm so I'm sitting
here and I'm like all right I'm
legitimately curious so some of them
were written reviews some of them are
like YouTube videos they all hated it
like really can't stand this book
because it apparently violates all the
principles of the lifestyle and that is
most evident in the end there it's
evident in some early scenes where he
pretty much just like grabs her throws
her down like ties her wrists together
and then just has at it with she never
gives any sort of consent she doesn't
stay she doesn't fight back either loser
it's dangerous that's es the show
say yeah she doesn't say she doesn't say
stop but it's vaguely kind of rapey I
don't know how else to wait because
she's nobody she doesn't really say stop
in the way that she plays it at least is
that hey I'm willing to kind of trip but
in a movie and here's where his peers
work it is fucking paperwork and here's
where this that is never signed here's
where the not having the inner monologue
really makes it more insidious to me
because in the inner monologue at least
you could be like oh my god it felt so
great oh I can't but without that and
you're just like what's going on in
their head if the scene plays even
creepier yeah you know like that it does
in something like the book so that
happens but the very end it's where it's
really painfully obvious because you're
exactly right he went through all of
this work to draft this contract that
was one of the few kind of funny scenes
in movie where she I think I like out
fisting strike and it's this business
meeting and according to my wife that
wasn't in the book as much they they
played it differently and actually maybe
once the film did better yeah I liked
the way you know and I get it was both
kind of funny but you know it's like
that worked for me and that was at you
again cuz they have to actually just
talk off each other work off if they
both know it's strange and they're both
being kind of playful but also very
strict and I thought that's the night
you played okay so we've set we've set a
couple of things up because it's very
important for how the ending plays and
why I think it's fucking ridiculous
we've set up that already so far he's
she's just bent over and taken it never
given the actual consent she just kind
of sits there and takes it
I guess we're left to assume she likes
it because she doesn't say anything but
it's still a set of weird scenes
particularly since she's a virgin like
some 27 that's Roger and he's just and
hilarious is like alright well literally
he literally is like all right well
we're gonna fucking fix that like just
takes her to the bedroom and I'm like
holy crap I'm like okay so that happens
there's a couple of other scenes where
he basically just like ties her to the
bed or whatever and she just takes it so
this has already happened there's this
whole bit about the contract and he is
adamant you have to sign the contract
you have son contract have you gotten to
me about the contract
contract contract she never never at
least in the movie signs the fucking
contract so so far she has given no
really oral consent has not really
agreed to anything just sits bends over
takes it does not sign the contract then
at the very end and he's the one who
insisted she sign it
this is not like I'm as good at it she
never does and then she asks him to go
full force he asks him and says show me
I insist that you fucking show me what
the hell you know is the full force or
whatever and he's like again Anna are
you sure are you sure yes so he bend
over you know straps her to some table
or whatever and then proceeds to whip
her ass was it ten times thirty thought
of not B says yeah he says it was ten
he's like you know count with me
you know one one two zero three n like
the scenes played up like she's in
legitimate real pain at no point does
she say stop and no point does not even
stop but or red or whatever I said yes
this is a big BDSM thing is there safe
words because sometimes if a if you're
getting into the role or whatever like
you're like oh oh shit Nez stop stop but
like you know no no I'm just playing
yeah so that's why you come up
apparently with a safe word that's some
crazy well it was Archer the banana
yeah banana but so she never once uses
this safe word she takes all ten and
then he lets her up as was agreed upon
and then she gets all pissy with him
because he did exactly what she had yeah
she's like you will never do that to me
again I was like but you fucking told
him to and then it's like I'm leaving
cuz you can't love me I fucking said I
wasn't gonna do that you know but I can
turn you I can do you know maybe that's
it maybe that's the element that like so
many people are like this is so
demeaning stuff is that it's playing on
the element that you can change him you
can change someone that seems really
sick and fucked up and stuff like that
you can make
no it's the crowds for a good
relationship there's no I mean really oh
yes if you can't see why it's not no no
but what what okay why it stands out
more than like any of the other elements
like why cuz like there's no see to me
it's to me it's painfully obvious like
yeah I mean it's painfully obvious the
issue to me is not that it's offensive
to women or condones abuse or this and
that
like that's just their you know the real
issue is are you taking it seriously or
is this just like any other fantasy like
some people want to be dominated some
people want to be sub and that's your
fan into whatever it's what's why when
you email dominatrixes like guys are
into it bring out the whips and some
girl in leather wit when I think it's
you know when they go to the ceiling is
when they go into the seriousness of a
like no no we're trying to tell a real
inori that's the problem so now you get
it like it's a fair point if you read
anybody can read Fifty Shades of Grey
and realize it if the author was taking
this seriously then she's out of her
freaking mind and this is just
ridiculous
and you know I think most women read
this because they know it's ridiculous
and it's just some porn ish fantasy well
yeah I mean it's very unbelievably rare
that a millionaire will come to you just
out of the blue random stranger and be
like I want you to be my sex mate it's
like saying zorn it's like seeing porn
is degrading to women of course it's
degrading to it that you know that's why
it's porn and it's the same thing with
this book that's what bothered me about
the film is it tries to take it
seriously and then an elevate and I'm
like no just admit it's garbage and we
can all recognize this garbage and go on
with our lives and if that's what you
find kinky and turns you on more power
to you I don't give a shit like but uh
yeah that whole ending makes no frickin
sense and and I said for something
that's supposed to as you said it'd be
garbage be smut it was lies are going
into you know get get their smut on and
stuff like that to try and suddenly have
this meaningful ending to something that
clearly has no me
- it is so bizarre and I think it
catches a you hit the rest of this film
had been is goofy and comedic as the
book is it may have been able to get
away with it because you've been would
have been like just the Saturday morning
cereal like oh this is like or it would
have been maybe the rare moment of
clarity and otherwise silly but yeah by
taking it so seriously then you have
that moment at the end you're just left
like scratching your head like what yeah
I guess because I didn't think there was
gonna be an ending like that and I don't
think mostly it sound like your audience
didn't think there was going to be and
like not that we had a ton of people at
ours they were all middle-aged uh but
you know we had enough that afterwards
done they were kind of like yeah a third
actually fat in line somewhere under
half of the audience I saw with this we
saw it opening night sirs pack house
couldn't find a seat like 1/3 to about
half of them literally groaned and we're
just ah like so you could tell they had
not read the books Brad in the audience
oh so um I'm sure Brad seen way better
porn oh no that's right his biggest
offense it's like it are you fucking
kidding me this is the intense now well
that's what brand night talk about I was
like this is my worst nightmare this is
just gonna be dull that's exactly what
it was so yeah definitely um by trying
to have this serious art house ending I
think you're right I think it actually
kind of makes it worse and it makes her
without the inner monologue I was I was
saying this to a couple of people when
you removed that inner monologue it
actually makes her look more insane
because you can't care of what's going
on in your head you only see these
actions and these actions are
nonsensical we're we're in the book
she's clearly nuts it makes no sense
she's clearly nuts but Alisha's you know
we're heading Lana T's coming I mean
this one I'm like wow you're not just
nuts you're a complete batshit crazy
schizo it's like because they're trying
to play that both of them are trying to
play them is like I don't want to say
definitely with her like an average
person and maybe the books trying to do
that too that it just does it so poorly
but with this because they're decent
actors uh you know they start to pull it
off which is why I think you're right
it's all the more troubling and strange
and kind of disturbing when they do make
these decisions that in the book you
just kind of laugh at like well it's so
terrible
way but in this one they're really
trying youkai legitimately are like what
the fuck is wrong with them almost
almost by their performance incredible
person only in the way that there's any
average girl in like a porno like I'm
just some 27 year old virgin and I'm
walking in and interviewing this rich
man there I mean you say it out loud
you're like this is ridiculous
like this is literally the plot to abort
it yeah head the film remembered that
like oh yeah this is a plot to a bad
porno movie so um will you show me I'm
blinkin her with the pencil and
everything like literally the only way
you could have made it more ridiculous
and more obvious is to put her in a like
a little schoolgirl outfit like with
like pigtails yeah like oh your kid is
what is your soul is what are but yeah
show you so um yeah take that for what
it's worth um it's a pretty stupid movie
uh if it will not be responsible for the
downfall of society that's the only
point where I lose it when Bieber tits
like I just so degrading to I'm like I
don't think you know this nobody can
take it seriously the handful of people
that don't realize that it's degrading
and ridiculous like they're far gone
like if you know somebody like that
please by all means instruct them and
get them to seek therapy but I think the
rest of the normal world knows that this
is just bullshit yeah that's partially
why people in Shu I know even with
Twilight I kinda you know I've I don't
like them and I I think they are you
know horrible role models for younger
people but at the same time I kind of
gave well I think you're right they are
more impressionable I gave them a little
bit more credit uh maybe I'm not as
cynical as I think I am cuz I just give
humans a little more credit than man I
know people will come and to be like but
I know the one person who takes it
seriously
nurse Annette Santa Donna Lella you see
just through the history I'll have left
their husbands because of Fifty Shades
of Grey much crap has come out in the
past that so many people said this is
gonna be the downfall of blank and it
hasn't been we survived showgirls well
we survived Emma
basically survives um we can survive
both the very talented and the very
untalented there were always I'm out
okay there will always be a five percent
of the population that will get sucked
up into something and just you know and
it's not woo if it's not one thing it'll
be enough yeah but that's who you need
to speak to the rest of us normal people
know this like you're preaching to the
choir like yes it's bullshit
we get it can we move on to something
else now please we say after we talk
about it for like a fucking hour yeah I
I'm ready for a gravity falls being long
how about you I'm in let's do it